[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the show and what
what a show we have for you today let's
start with projection and voting the
level at which the right is projecting
their actions onto the left has really
come to a head on the topic of this
recent florida election and subsequent
recount that is going on it is now being
reported that a heavily Republican
county in florida has allowed some
residents wait for it to vote by email
which you might be wondering about and
yes indeed
that is against the law I'm gonna reset
the entire story for you so that we all
sort of have all of the same information
on which to base our analysis so let's
go back a couple of years four years now
the right has been saying we need voter
ID we need all sorts of other voter
suppression policies because of voter
fraud mostly perpetrated by the left
they said people are voting for others
people are voting twice dead people are
voting not really the live people are
going and saying they are people who
have actually died the reality is that
that's not a problem
okay there's been a huge meta-analysis
by the brennan center for justice which
found that there were in something like
1.3 billion ballots cast around 30
individual instances of fraud over like
a 14 year period or something like that
i mean the numbers were just
infinitesimally small so we cut to last
week the florida elections happen it's
very close in the senate race it's very
close in the gubernatorial race and you
see on election night republicans in the
lead of rick scott in the senate and ron
DeSantis apparently winning on election
night we then find out
that there are a whole bunch of ballots
which simply haven't been counted many
of them found at a mail handling
facility in a liberal part of the state
miami-dade County irregularities in
Broward County another one of the three
sort of big blue counties of Florida
that are responsible for a lot of the
Democratic votes in these elections
we've got questionable Val 'its that
voting machines disqualified that we
need to look at by hand to really get a
final tally Republicans immediately say
oh this is voter fraud by Democrats
they're sort of implying that Democrats
dropped off bags of ballots after the
election was over at a mail facility and
of course there's no evidence of foul
play or fraud and if Democrats had a
plan of swinging the election with the
bags of paper ballots they would have
number one gotten them in before
Election Day actually took place and
number two they probably wouldn't have
dropped them off in a liberal area since
that would attract exactly this type of
attention so if Democrats are trying to
steal the election with paper ballots
dropped off late in a blue area they are
really doing something very stupid by
way of or in the hopes of swinging the
election fraudulently so over the last
few days we've had Republicans doing
everything they can to oppose the
recounts Donald Trump claiming voter
fraud with no evidence Sean Hannity on
Fox News saying someone should go to
jail for this and we've now learned that
in a very Republican County in Florida
this is Bay County where in 2016 Donald
Trump had 71 percent of the vote in the
presidential election the election
supervisor in Bay County his name's Marc
Anderson he has admitted he's not even
denying that he has allowed people to
vote by email this is against the law
this is not allowed now you can argue we
should have voting by email in the
United States we should have electronic
voting or you could argue that we
shouldn't but what you can't argue is
that we don't so this is against the law
this is a form
of fraudulent voting that the election
supervisor has admitted to why did this
happen they say that it's because of the
hurricane but it's just not adding up
because after the hurricane on October
10th rick Scott who is not only the
senator elect in Florida he's also the
governor he put out an executive order
saying we're gonna extend early voting
we're going to add early voting
locations but no votes can be submitted
by email or fax like he specifically
addressed that issue and people were
allowed by the election supervisor to
scan or take pictures of their ballots
and email them in and the election
supervisor is defending it by saying we
are simply taking care of voters Pat
what about taking care of voters by
making it easier to vote what about
taking care of voters by expanding
voting locations or early voting not
because of a hurricane but just because
it's the right thing to do or not
purging voter rolls no they don't do any
of that stuff but now they want to help
voters by allowing a Republican County
to vote by email which is against the
law yeah sounds to me like voter fraud
and I estimate that anywhere from three
to five million people voted illegally
my thought is that we have to put
together a voter integrity Commission to
really get down to the bottom of the
bottom of this because Democrats should
have won both of these races it makes
more sense here than it did after the
2016 election that's for sure because
these are hundreds of instances of what
Donald Trump claimed three to five
million people did in 2016
without any actual evidence and just as
I mean while we're talking about Trump
Trump said he would prosecute all
election fraud voting by email is a form
of election fraud is it going to be
prosecuted
I guess Rick Scott was right there
actually was a voter fraud problem here
but not in miami-dade County not in
Broward County in heavily Republican Bay
County you cannot write this stuff in
completely inappropriate news today we
learned that first lady Melania Trump
ordered the firing of a national
security staffer and that that person
has in
been fired Mira Ricard el has been the
deputy national security advisor to the
president working below national
security adviser John Bolton
since May of this year May of 2018 and
recently the first lady and Ricard el
went to Africa and it turns out that
Ricard el was not getting along with
Melania Trump's staff one report says
that the disagreements included where
people were going to sit on the flight
to Africa not exactly serious
life-altering stuff but they weren't
getting along
Ricardo also previously was having some
conflicts with defense secretary Jim
mattis there have been reports of
tension between Ricard el and
potentially soon to be fired chief of
staff John Kelly that's another story
but the chaos in the White House and
then yesterday reportedly catching the
White House off guard Melania Trump
Sophos put out a statement saying that
quote it is the position of the office
of the first lady and that Ricard el no
longer deserves the honor of serving in
this White House and hours after that we
learned that indeed Mira Ricard el has
been fired by Donald Trump the first
lady publicly slammed a national
security staffer and reports are that
neither Trump nor chief of staff John
Kelly nor press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders knew that the statement was
going to be put out they were caught off
guard and indeed that staffer has now
been fired the first lady's office is
making decisions about who handles
national security in the United States
of America if you are National Security
Advisor John Bolton Pat and one of your
staffers has been fired because the
first lady didn't like her what do you
do now what is John Bolton going to do
about the fact that the first lady is
making staffing decisions for him this
is a new level of ridiculousness and
absurdity isn't it I don't know I don't
know because I think if you look at
American history first ladies have had
different levels of influence Hillary
Clinton for example was in charge of
pioneering and
championing universal health care and
the violence against women at woman's
act and I know the Bellagio boys has
played a secondary role like she's
playing you know backseat position here
in the White House she hasn't been that
vocal and active in forming policy but
if she wants to get a particular staffer
fired particularly one who hasn't been
Senate confirmed I think it's fair game
that's my take on it this is not Melania
being best as she likes to say and just
consider for a second okay so Hillary
tried to do health care in the 90s fine
if it had leaked that Michelle Obama
privately influenced the firing of even
a speechwriter to Barack Obama Fox News
and Rush Limbaugh would have been
covering it wall to wall every single
day for months this was a public
statement about a national security
staffer the second-in-command to John
Bolton by the first lady this is
actually an important job related to
national security and we're barely
hearing a word about it from the
right-wing media that they are pathetic
hypocrites and you can say Pat that
Hillary Clinton was involved in trying
to do health care okay that's one thing
but Hillary Clinton was not at least in
this way deciding through public
statements who gets fired by the
President of the United States if your
argument is well listen David this stuff
is going on behind the scenes either way
this is just the the White House the the
first lady's office rather making a
public statement about it it doesn't
change the fact that this is actually
happening behind the scenes all the time
okay well we can look at that argument
and then we can debate it on its merits
but the idea that Melania Trump knows
anything about who should be in a
position of ensuring the national
security of the United States is
unquestionably unfounded I mean we can't
defend that can we Pat but do you see
any difference between a national
security staffer someone who is not
Senate confirmed and say someone who is
in a cabinet position like a Secretary
of State like can you can you make a
difference between the two of those
things there is a difference but either
way Melania Trump is not qualified to do
side who is the number two national
security person in the United States yes
she's not saying fire the Secretary of
State that would be different but this
is still plenty bad I feel like there
are maybe a thousand things that we can
criticize going on in the Trump
administration right now and for me this
just doesn't rank that highly on the
list
in regards to that right-wing media
point that you made I think that they're
just way too busy covering the caravan
covering the midterm election recounts
there there's a lot of stuff going on
right now it's a fear monger about well
we've now got a thousand and one things
on that list and this is certainly one
of them I got one email which said hey
David there's no way that Melania did
this without approval this is clearly a
plot to distract from something else
maybe upcoming indictments from Muller
well it did leak that supposedly molar
indictments are coming soon but this is
a little too well orchestrated for it to
be a calculated distraction I don't even
give them that much credit send me your
thoughts are you more on the pat side of
the Melania dictating who is in charge
of national security of the United
States or are you more on my side of
this or is there some other position we
haven't considered the show is on
Twitter a David Pakman show I am on
Twitter at D Pakman follow us and let me
know your thoughts the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com let me say a quick thank you
to Christopher Phillips who's today's
new member of the day thank you we are
mostly funded by viewers and listeners
like Christopher Phillips also want to
thank a longtime member Rex Michener who
has been with us for five years five
years of membership Rex has been with us
since November of 2013 Christopher Rex
thanks to both of you join them at WWJ
in pakman.com we do depend on the
support of our viewers that's how the
program is primarily funded and I really
appreciate everybody who has signed up
over the last several days including
since the midterms ok it is sort of a
new era
for hatred mail the era of Trump and
we've seen the even further debasement
of the hate mail that is coming in
regularly it's scary in many ways it
leads to more contacts with law
enforcement that's for sure if you don't
know what I'm talking about what is
hatred mail this is hatred mail we're so
all right it's wrong
hatred mail written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom yes so it was Veterans Day this
week and we have a hatred mail here I
guess in that theme from someone
claiming to be a veteran although can we
really believe anything that Patriots
say I don't know let's take a listen to
it together see if we can make heads or
tails out of it
look [ __ ] Pakman if you served this
country as I have went overseas and saw
what these this so-called devout Muslim
bastards did to our servicemen you would
be anti-muslim too so [ __ ] off bleeding
heart NPC betta cook male loser
you keep getting better-looking and more
intelligent every day give me a break
who say who saying that I that's not
he's arguing against praise that I've
not actually heard made of me
but what you might notice there is that
there's a big focus on masculinity and
today's voicemail later on in the show
actually addresses that exact issue
issue so I'm going to come back to that
for now I'll just remind you that you
can send a message of a middle finger to
the hey tree 'it's by making a new
membership at WWJ in pokémon calm with
the coupon code hey treat for tea every
time you use the coupon code hatred for
tea 297 hatreds cry you get a membership
at 40% off and independent progressive
media wins h atri ot is the coupon code
use it unlimited uses are available
right now very interesting new study
about religious groups in the United
States that I want to discuss with you
the fastest growing religious group in
the country
is no religion in other words people who
don't associate with any particular
religion and this is not a new trend
this is actually something that we've
been seeing for a while every time pew
the pew religion center does this report
on I believe it's a yearly basis and
we're actually seeing the increased
number of people not affiliated with
religion have real measurable impact so
churches are closing all around the
country or are having to merge
communities that used to have six
churches if you can imagine it in some
cases are merging and combining and end
up sometimes with only two or three
churches we're seeing more political
candidates than ever not professing a
religion many at the local level more at
the state level notably Kyrsten Sinema
who recently has taken over victory of
her Senate seat from Arizona over
Republican martha mcsalley the first
senator to not profess a religion so
we're seeing this more and more and the
Pew Research Center as I mentioned again
has their study on this issue out and
not surprisingly when we break these
results down by age the younger you are
the more likely you are to select none
as your religion if looking at the
results here as we are together you'll
notice that the Silent Generation born
between 28 and 45 has nearly 90 percent
of its constituents professing a
religion whereas baby boomers and more
so Generation X and more so older
Millennials and even more so younger
Millennials at 36% profess that they are
not affiliated with any religion when
people are interviewed about having left
typically it's their Christian Church
merely from a from a numbers perspective
most people in the u.s. at least
nominally identify as Christian when
they identify with a religion people are
asked well why did you leave sometimes
they talk about you know the teachings
don't relate to real life I don't feel
like there's any connection between the
teachings and my actual life or the
rituals don't mean anything to me or I
actually am just bored or uninterested
in the rituals there's a lot of that but
I actually have a more sort of
evolutionary perspective on the fading
of religion Pat for me it's sort of like
a survival of the fittest or natural
selection kind of approach to the fading
of religion in the United States of
America
historically survival has been very
accurately predicted by the ability of
individuals and groups to cooperate if
this init can include in small numbers
this can also include in large numbers
and one of the big distinguishing
factors between Homo sapiens and earlier
humans and Homo sapiens and other
species is that Homo sapiens can
cooperate in very large numbers in
flexible ways so to give you counter
examples chimpanzees can cooperate
flexibly they can cooperate in foraging
or hunting or building shelters simple
shelters in some cases whatever but they
can only do that in small groups like
chimpanzees can't organize themselves in
a group of five hundred bees are an
example of a species that can coordinate
in huge numbers beehives with thousands
of bees they can coordinate but only
inflexibly on very narrow tasks if bees
all of a sudden need to coordinate 5,000
bees to file a tax return I mean it's a
dumb example but on something something
bigger they're not able to do it and
humans can cooperate flexibly in large
numbers years ago many many years ago
being part of a religious group
increased your chances of survival
people who helped you
religion increased collaboration for
in-group members we know that that's the
case and therefore you actually had a
higher chance of survival of living long
enough to have children and pass along
your genes that is now less likely to
happen you're not as likely to suffer in
2018 as a result of being unable to
cooperate with mankind because you're
not part of a religious group it's less
necessary it's less advantageous in 2018
to be part of a religious group it's no
longer an issue of survival not to be
religious if you look even today at
places where you're less likely to
survive as an atheist there are fewer
atheists the evolutionary advantage
to religious belief still exists in some
places like look at a country Yemen is
an example in Yemen the population says
that religion is extraordinarily
important to them something like 98 99
percent of the population says religion
is extraordinarily important in Yemen
there probably is a measurably higher
chance of dying before reproducing if
you're not religious
contrast that with someplace like Norway
or Sweden some of the least religious
countries in the world there's no real
advantage to religion in the survival
sense there's no cooperation advantage
in Norway or Sweden to being part of a
church or a religious group so we can
look at this a few different ways yes
the more we learn about how the world
works the more that science explains
things about the world the decreased
need for religion is noticed and that is
a factor but there's also this other
sort of evolutionary angle and there is
one concern here Pat which is that
religion being none is fine but if
people are replacing religion with this
vague new age not really religion but
pretty horrible ideas connected to
pseudoscience that's something I would
be very careful about you are you saying
that I should return all the Jade eggs I
bought from the GUP website when a
Paltrow's website yeah no more vaginal
steaming Pat we've got to stop that it's
extraordinarily dangerous and you need
to tell everybody in your family who's
doing it that they need to stop right
away and we're kind of kidding but there
are a lot of really bad ideas right now
under the umbrella not of organized
religious belief but more sort of
agnostic teachings and and anti-vaccine
sentiment the pseudoscience stuff that
Pat's bringing up that's based on or
advertised on Gwyneth Paltrow's website
goop the type of garbage that dr. oz
promotes it's really important to keep
an eye on that but the trend with
organized religion is very clear it's
dwindling in the United States and the
biggest upside for me like you know you
could say David we should care about
people believing things without evidence
no matter whether they're doing it
privately or publicly
luckily or both fine we can argue it's
not good for people to literally believe
that if you eat shrimp you're going to
hell or whatever right I mean whatever
the teachings are the biggest upside for
me though is in the end if people
believe whatever they believe privately
if it doesn't impact what they want to
have happen in the public sphere if they
are okay with total separation of church
and state I don't really care what they
believe privately although I might
disagree with it the upside for me of
more people in the United States
professing none as their religion is
that it should allow it to be easier for
our elected officials to be much more
clear much more direct much more
black-and-white on the issue of
secularism meaning a total separation of
church and state and that that's a good
thing because that's actually a
principle the country was founded on and
now here's my question to you or my
proposal to you if you're hearing me
tell this story of people moving away
from religion in the United States and
you think it's bad you think it would be
better for people in the United States
to remain more religious or to move back
towards religion please get in touch
with me and let me know why why is it
bad that people are moving away from
religion in the United States I want to
hear from you we will also ask for
thoughts on this via our Instagram
account instagram.com slash david pakman
show make sure you're following us there
and also follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman you can find behind the scenes
pictures of the new studio and much more
we will take a quick break what a
program we have for
today the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it is great to be joined
today by carl cederstrom who's associate
professor at Stockholm Business School
at Stockholm University also author of
the book the happiness fantasy Carl it's
so great to talk to you today and we're
going to talk about an issue that sort
of relates to an interview we did
yesterday actually about how
corporations and tech billionaires have
in many ways co-opted what is sort of
safe activism activism they're okay with
but that doesn't really challenge the
status quo and sort of related to that
is the idea of the concept of happiness
in Western society and how that also has
been significantly influenced by the
idea of happiness that is sort of useful
or beneficial to corporations so can we
talk about that a little bit and maybe
first to begin with even more generally
when we talk about measuring happiness
what are we really measuring how can we
do that what are some of the methods
that exist well there are a lot of
methods out there but briefly I would
say that we don't really know what we
measure apart from what people believe
to be happiness at that particular
moment and we've done really fascinating
studies where they just make very very
minor changes to the configuration or
the setting of one of these sort of a
happiness survey settings and you could
see that the change of the result is
very significant but let's say if you go
back 2,000 years and hand out one of
those happiness surveys you're probably
going to find about the same result that
you get today I mean the average score
is usually 7.5 from 1 to 10 point scale
and what we lack is a
condition of of happiness or rather we
have too many definitions of happiness
we've got millions of different
definitions and and it's because
happiness is a philosophical question
and we don't know what it is and I'm
afraid to say that we're never going to
fully find out what it is because it's
basically tantamount to something as
elusive as what does it mean to live a
good meaningful life so when we in
thinking about the difficulty of
actually coming up with one sort of
stable definition over a long period of
time of what we mean can you talk a
little bit about how the perception of
what happiness is has shifted in human
history just to sort of and introduce
that idea to the conversation what are
sort of aspects of happiness that might
have been prevalent thousands of years
ago that maybe no longer are today well
I think the major shift we see in the
Enlightenment because it's only then
that happiness becomes something that
we're not only supposed to strive
towards but something that we should
attain prior to that point happiness was
something that we couldn't really
achieve as human beings it was basically
to reserve of the gods this was the idea
of happiness in ancient Greece for
instance you should pursue happiness
which to the Greek
Greeks was the same as trying to become
an ethical human being and develop a set
of virtuous faculties and you know
during the Middle Ages in Christianity
happiness didn't really exist in the
life on earth it was something that you
would get when you were dead for having
done your duty on on earth so it's
really only in the Enlightenment that we
get happiness is something that we are
able to attain but even up to the you
know the beginning of the 20th century
half this was still regarded as
something that was very very difficult
if not impossible to achieve what you
would find in worked from Freud's is
only really in the 1950s that we begin
to have this idea that happiness is
something that everyone could achieve
and in the 1950s the idea of happiness
in the United States in particular was
very closely bound up with the happy
housewife who would spend her days with
the kids and
husband who would go to work and then
come home and ask for a whiskey and the
family would be all happy together it
was a sense of happiness built around
the family and security and then of
course just a decade after in the 1960s
that changes in a very very drastic
manner when happiness is by no means to
be sort or searched for within the
family but instead something I was about
breaking free from the different norms
and you know the kind of chains of
societies it was then very closely
connected to personal liberation
personal growth and living a life in
freedom so it would it be fair to say
that we'll get to the more recent impact
of consumer culture on the pursuit of
happiness but before we step into that
would it be fair to say that happiness
maybe longer ago was considered more of
a process whereas now or it shifted more
recently to something that you can kind
of achieve and that's it you've done it
and the the chapter is sort of closed I
think it's fair to say that and and
obviously today everyone is selling and
offering happiness in all its forms we
even have you know something you can
drink that would offer you happiness or
you're supposed to get happiness from
from anything so yeah I think that's
fair to say it had a much more long-term
process perspective in the past and it
has now so then we can now introduce the
idea of consumer culture and products
and services and wellness and all of
this other stuff have we seen a decline
in self-reported happiness in the time
period since this consumer culture has
developed and if so is it more acute in
certain countries than in others it's
impossible to say if the happiness level
when you search when you look at that
would have decreased or increased
because as I said at the outset if you
do this service you would tend to get
pretty much the same kind of asks if you
only focus on what people say when they
are being asked are you happy or not but
I think it's fair
say that the society will live in today
where so many people are living on very
very little money and they are living
under precarious circumstances and they
feel a great degree of anxiety and the
rest of it I think it's fair to say that
this is sense of unhappiness that has
been very widespread and which I would
argue is strongly connected to material
circumstances people not being able to
create a life that they are at the same
time being promised I think the crucial
point now is that we're still being sold
this idea that everyone could become a
great success story through a kind of
personal growth trajectory where you end
up actualizing yourself but then at the
same time you could see statistically
that so many people are think something
up to a third of the American population
were under the poverty level for two
months between 2009 and 2011 so I think
it's a very kind of cruel vocabulary and
Sharan that we find not least among
politicians who would say that everyone
could be happy if only they tried hard
enough and yet at the same time we know
that those same people or very many
people in a way are living on the very
unhappy circumstances so it seems like
there's sort of three ideas that I want
to broach now and see what you think of
them which one is maybe more or less
important or just kind of get your
thoughts here number one is that
statistically most people are not going
to be sort of at the top when it comes
to income when it comes to well bright
like mathematically speaking the 1% is
only 1% of the population so that that's
sort of one problem in terms of
expectations number two is this concept
of hedonic adaptation which is that once
you achieve a new level of status money
personal items that you now own and have
access to a bigger house a more
expensive car you very quickly become
acclimated to that it becomes your new
baseline and you're not actually any
happier
than you were when that's what you were
striving for long ago and then number
three that I would introduce is the idea
that a lot of happiness or satisfaction
is dictated not actually by what you
have or have achieved but how it
compares to what others around you have
achieved and that's sort of where we get
into a conversation about inequality and
the negative impacts of that these three
issues is there one in your mind that
you think is most important have I
mentioned something that you don't think
is important I think probably the first
one is the one that speaks to me most
directly and the reason for that is the
way we think about happiness today is so
deeply influenced by self-help
literature and the self-help culture
that has really came to come to dominate
our lives and there is one self-help
book which is very well known called the
secret where there's a collection of
voices who would explain what a secret
is basically it's having fine this law
of attraction which means that if you
just put your mind to it in the right
way you will be able to govern your life
and everything that happens to you
through your own thought patterns and
they do say at one point there's only
one percent of the people who have
really figured out the secret so in
other words then the point I'm trying to
make here is that the kind of self-help
culture that has come to define
happiness for us today
is really trying to deep politicize our
surroundings our circumstances the lives
we live and basically say that anyone
could be happy but probably just about
one percent because it's only really
those 1 percent who have put their mind
to it and that means that the 99 percent
who don't have the same degree of power
and wealth just have themselves to blame
and that is the kind of rhetoric that
has become so prevalent and dominant in
our notion of happiness and and that is
something I find really problematic so
let's now introduce into this how
corporations have sort
guided and defined the image of
happiness that we have really for their
own benefit right for the benefit of
selling the product or service that they
offer we can either
I if you have specific examples that's
great if you want to talk a little more
generally about the role of the
corporation and and public relations and
advertising in guiding what we see is
happiness either way I think that that's
the next idea to introduce yes I mean we
could see a very significant shift
taking place in the 1970s so if the
1960s was a decade where a lot of people
they'd want to break free from the
demands they had felt previously that
they had to live this very boring secure
life then in the 1970s a lot of
corporations were struggling to find
ways of making work appetizing and
especially to try and attract young
talented people to the workplace and you
had several business gurus who hit upon
what they thought was a brilliant idea
at the time which was that corporations
and executives should start using the
vocabulary of the 1960s they were Cabul
era of authenticity of liberation of
freedom and so in the 1970s more and
more corporations really started to pick
up on this language and then in the
1980s you can see how the really
successful personal growth centers
started to design courses especially
designed for executives and HR people so
people would leave their offices and
they would go on these retreats to find
themselves but also to find ways of
becoming more successful at their work
so you would find how the kind of spirit
of personal growth self-actualization
and finding inner meaning became so
repackaged as a way of also becoming
better and plead and interestingly in
the 1980s you would find some really
well-known corporations including IBM
and Lera Strauss using the exact same
words and phrases that were ad
developed in the 1960s around a human
potential movement and human
potentiality first coined by Aldous
Huxley who was probably most known for
the book brave new world but also for
experimenting with psychedelic drugs and
being a little pioneer in the nineteen
sixties movement of spiritual awakening
and all the rest of that and and other
things are also happening in in nineteen
seventies you would find personal growth
seminars becoming wildly popular there's
one of them that I write about in a book
I started by a man called Werner Erhard
is some name that he took the seminar
centers called s Erhard seminars rannian
people winter for weekend long training
and what we were being taught
specifically was that there are no
victims in the world and also if they
only found the right way of thinking
about the reality and themselves they
would be able to come back and change
their lives around so you could become
the person they really wanted to be and
so this is really a story it's only real
it's really under until nineteen eight
it's a lot of corporations start to pick
up on that and then in the 1990s we had
the big boom of corporate cultures and
this has really is an ongoing trend that
we could see today really how it has
culminated in some really bizarre in
some really bizarre examples so for
instance there's a UK sandwich selling
fast food chain where the employees
basically the people who stand by the
cashier and sell sandwiches are expected
not just to be happy but to be
authentically happy and there are cases
how employees have been disciplined when
they hadn't lived up to this I think
when it's come to that point the
corporation's giving a minimum wage or
close to to their employees and forcing
them not just to smile but to have that
sense of I am a liberated free authentic
human being there's something that isn't
quite right and that really
the bottom line of what what I try to
tell in this book the history from how
the idea of self-actualization a human
potentiality which made a lot of sense
as a form of happiness in the 1960s if
you saw the contrast to the 1950s and
how people felt really regulated and and
suppressed you could see how from the
1960 to today the notion of happiness
and self-actualization have really been
very important tools for politicians and
corporations but what him but the result
is that this is not I think I kind of
happiness that one could truly believe
in yeah I mean the the mandating of
authentic happiness reminds me of a
scene in the film office space office
space where the Jennifer Aniston
character is told she doesn't have
enough pieces of flair on her uniform
and she says well how many pieces do you
want me to have and the manager says
it's not about how many I want you to
have it's I want you to want to have
more pieces of flair on your uniform and
it's that idea of sort of mandating a
certain type of authenticity very very
interesting we've been speaking with
Karl cederstrom who's an associate
professor at Stockholm Business School
in Stockholm University the book is the
happiness fantasy which I encourage you
to check out Karl thanks so much for
talking to me today thank you my
pleasure to be on the show the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so CNN is now suing Donald Trump and the
White House and some White House
staffers for revoking Jim Acosta's press
pass after an incident involving an
intern last week and I know most of you
have probably already heard about this
issue if you haven't this all started
during a moment at a press conference
given by Donald Trump during which CNN
reporter Jim Acosta was questioning
Donald Trump and in so doing Donald
Trump sort of made it clear that he
didn't want to hear from Jim Acosta
anymore and as you have seen maybe by
now many times a White House intern came
over to Jim Acosta and started trying to
physically remove the microphone from
his hands Jim Acosta persisted and sort
of said pardon me ma'am and at a certain
point his arm gets entangled with the
White House interns and the argument
that the White House made after the fact
for Jim Acosta's press past being
revoked was that in that moment he put
hands on a woman and that that wasn't
okay sort of making almost like a
violence against women type of argument
as she and and as her in his arms became
entangled and what the CNN lawsuit is
saying is that by revoking his press
pass Jim Acosta's first and Fifth
Amendment rights were violated now the
First Amendment we know about we're
talking about freedom of speech the
government can't limit speech without a
really good reason the government can't
limit speech on the basis of the
viewpoint of a reporter or media outlet
for example and it certainly seems as
though Donald Trump doesn't like CNN and
Jim Acosta for what he perceives to be
their political point of view and thus
the lawsuit claims Jim Acosta First
Amendment rights have been violated then
we get to the fifth Amendment argument
and that relates to due process the
government can't take away someone's
property without due process
they took Jim Acosta's physical press
pass but they also took away sort of the
pathway to him doing his job as White
house reporter and there was no due
process at least according to the
lawsuit they shared the white house
shared a doctored video of the incident
and then said we're banning him we're
revoking his Press credential and what
CNN is asking for here is a preliminary
injunction which would immediately
reinstate Jim Acosta's access to the
press briefings White House is saying
that the lawsuit is merely political
grandstanding there is no denying that
this has been really good for Jim
Acosta's brand he's gained hundreds of
thousands of Twitter followers since
this happened if he was able to force
his way back into the briefings it would
be fantastic
for getting himself more attention and
it would be I admit amazingly awkward in
the best way possible to have him back
in the room they're trying to ask Donald
Trump questions the real question is
whether the arguments made in the
lawsuit will stick and we're going to
see there is precedent for a Fifth
Amendment due process argument here
there's a case from 1977 called Cheryl
versus night and it involves a
journalist named Robert Cheryl and the
decision from the court concluded that
if the White House is going to deny or
revoke a press pass they need to follow
a pretty specific process and what it
appears was the case here is that that
wasn't done the White House certainly
might try to retro actively create a
paper trail and argue that actually they
did go through that process but it
doesn't appear as though that's the case
and we're going to see where this works
out you know Pat I mean as far as the
First Amendment it's tough to argue you
know CNN hasn't been banned
it's just Jim Acosta who's Press Pass
has been revoked
and if CNN can send another reporter
there you can probably make the case
that First Amendment is not an issue
that Jim Acosta has no right to be at
press briefings I actually think that
the due process fifth amendment argument
on the basis of the 1977 precedent maybe
the stronger argument here but do you
think that this is a quote serious
lawsuit or do you think that it's to get
something on the record and the key
getting the story more attention I think
it's all designed to make it so that
this is just a headache for the White
House and that the easiest thing for
them to do is to reinstate Jim Acosta's
Press Pass because they don't want to go
through legal proceedings over something
like this but hey good on CNN for
sticking by Jim Acosta I was worried
that maybe they would just replace him
and that his replacement would ask much
softer questions not be as adversarial
with Trump as Jim Acosta was but know
they're going all in here in that
lawsuit shows it yeah and even Fox News
actually put out an editorial
earlier today saying we are on the side
of Jim Acosta here we are against this
revoking of press passes on what seemed
to be more political and personality
lines than anything actually
journalistically wrong that that was
that was done that we can definitively
say what I want to hear from you about
in the audience is do you think the
lawsuit is serious do you think it's a
way to get attention do you think it's
both do you think it's something else
let me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman I
have something very exciting to announce
today Pat I have been sworn to secrecy
on this for months as it has been
developing and I am now cleared to tell
you that the David Pakman show
is part of a select group of podcasts
which are going to be part of Pandora's
new podcast offerings Pandora is this
huge music discovery and streaming
service many of you I know use it
already they have decided to jump into
the fray with podcasting they're going
to launch podcasts sometime in the next
four to six weeks and this is just going
to be huge for the David Pakman show and
for our podcast we are already on
Spotify iTunes I Heart Radio stitcher
and getting on Pandora is absolutely
massive for us sometime in December I am
told you will be able to subscribe to
and listen to the david pakman show
podcast on Pandora this is again an
invite-only
curated group of podcasts
and what else can I say Pat this is just
great for the show yeah I'm actually
kind of nervous do you want me to change
anything about the production here on my
end how about my my my tone and tenor on
the show do we have to adjust in
language police to fit pandora's
platform oh yeah we're gonna be doing
all sorts of language policing of Pat
and there's gonna be there's gonna be
actually a list of banned words Keurig
is going to be one of them feral cats is
not a phrase that will ever be allowed
on the program again and there's gonna
be a whole list of banned words for Pat
now that we are on Pandora
no I'm kidding but listen sign up to be
notified you can use if you're watching
on YouTube there's a link in the video
description if you are listening you can
sign up to be notified about these new
podcast offerings on Pandora the website
is Pandora podcast beta dot splash that
com Pandora podcast beta splash dot-com
this is uh this is all good for what I
believe are going to be the biggest two
years in politics since the David Pakman
show went on the air these next two
years I've been talking about that now
for a week since the midterms and
possibly the biggest two years
politically in my lifetime at least
maybe American politics at this time a
lot is riding on the next two years
membership patreon subscribe to the
Pandora beta subscribe on YouTube
anything all of it all much appreciated
we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p today's voicemail
relates to something that has really
become an issue actually over the last
several years and particularly under
donald trump for Republicans and the
topic is masculinity let's take a listen
to today's voicemail hey David a real
big fan of the show I kinda want to ask
you strange question
you sometimes mentioned that Trump
supporters really want him to be sort of
the Alpha in the room and I guess I just
wanted to ask about that more broadly
because the surprising does come up
quite a bit the sort of fixation the
fixation mostly by conservatives on
masculinity like Jesse Lee Peterson
asking you what is the man
and you know you're very familiar with
the kind of me to emasculate call people
cook it's funny but it comes up well
what is that do you think it's the sort
of a just a psychological glitch like I
know how likely you are to be disgusted
disgust sensitivity is positively
correlated with conservatism is it
something like that is it something else
and secondly since you've dealt with
quite a bit being in the media yourself
how do you manage the people like that
and you even push back is it worth it I
think so the second part is sort of
easier for me which is that if someone's
main critiques of me are that I am an
npc SOI boy beta cuck I'm not
particularly interested in engaging I'm
just not but the first part is very
interesting which is why is there this
hyper focus on masculinity and
identifying who is masculine who is not
masculine I think this actually relates
to you know the part of the obsession
from the write about gay marriage and
transgenderism is religiously based some
of it is simply bigotry but I actually
think that a lot of it is connected to
these preconceived notions and hang-ups
on masculinity that the right has and I
don't know Pat why they're so obsessed
with the degree of masculinity and who
is the most masculine politician and
this is alpha and that's beta but it
could be one one argument would be this
is something they are insecure about and
thus it becomes like a primary narrative
even the sort of guy I know people will
say not all men's rights activists or
right wing but men's rights activism is
more on the right than it is on the left
even that I feel like is based in and
perceived sort of shortcomings that they
perceive about themselves when it comes
to masculinity I don't know what the
source of it is we could say it's
religion we could say it's educational I
don't know but it is an obsession and
isn't it odd or ironic that they all
view Trump as their alpha male to whom
they must be so
surveyance at all times and I guess
Trump really isn't all that alpha-2 he
did miss that World War 1 ceremony
because of rain after all and dodged the
Vietnam War five deferments all that
stuff but yeah I don't think they have a
very even standard when it comes to that
sort of stuff no they certainly don't
and this is a problem that they have and
it's something we should explore in more
detail I'm out of time great bonus show
today hope to talk to you on the bonus
show in near minutes
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you